so this is fascinating because somebody
asked me recently what did I think would
get us out of this bear market right and
I said there's gotta be some kind of
catalyst right that will that will
create some inflection point and I said
you know it's a retail product that's
one option
not necessary because I think people
have a hard time buying Bitcoin but it's
more of legitimacy insurance custody all
that kind of stuff
another could be that it's just some
huge institution reveals that they've
got you know a position that no one
knows about right so if you know a
sovereign wolf comes out says listen
we've bought you know billions of
dollars worth of Bitcoin right something
like that where again you just get a
bunch of legitimacy but the Third Point
happened then like capital inflows you
know that would really drastically yeah
well and so here's the third one and
actually one I think doesn't get talked
a lot about and you just mentioned so
it's worth spending time on is if there
is an economic chaos that occurs in a
specific region or country that causes
people to flow into Bitcoin for example
because it is the best option available
it's almost we get a watch it play out
as an example yes I don't think it even
has to be economic I think if we look at
the political climate in a lot of
economies we look you know globalization
was the theme in the 1990s and the 2000s
and now what we started to see is like
yes globalization has changed the world
integrated market it's more efficient
markets more assets more capital more
cash has lifted a lot of people out of
poverty like objectively speaking if we
look at the data
people are living a better quality of
life there is more wealth in our world
than there was in the past but
inequality has grown and I think this is
the the challenging part is a lot of
what's happening it's social there's a
lot of social unrest there's a lot of
political unrest and there's a lot of
uncertainty and fear even in even with
investors absolutely we look at what's
happening in equities like the the Dow
hit 25,000 and everyone's like peak peak
sell liquidate um what are we gonna do
and it kept going up everything feels
overvalued you look at real estate real
still state feels overbought VC
everything's overvalued
and so investors are looking at the
world at this macro environment they're
like in a world where everything feels
overvalued and overbought in a world
where we're really not sure where alphas
gonna come from
what do we do absolutely I think that
creates a lot of room and I think again
what we as an industry need to start to
think about is how do we win hearts and
minds